la Unión Europea y el Reino Unido han
alcanzado un nuevo acuerdo sobre el
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte tras
meses de negociaciones El Primer
Ministro británico dijo que lo pactado
salvaguarda la soberanía de Irlanda del
Norte mientras que la presidenta de la
comisión europea señaló que el nuevo
marco de Windsor protege a sus mercados
el gobierno francés planea reducir la
presencia de su ejército en África así
lo expuso el presidente Manuel macron
durante la presentación de su plan para
el continente a días de un viaje que lo
llevará de gira por cuatro países
centroafricanos
las autoridades de Ecuador investigan el
asesinato del líder indígena Eduardo
mendúa Quien murió a tiros en la noche
de este domingo la policía detuvo a un
sospechoso por los hechos que se
produjeron en la provincia de sucumbíos
en el noreste del país Tenemos reporte
desde Ecuador
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición de nuevo con la
información de que Reino Unido y la
Unión Europea han alcanzado un acuerdo
para el nuevo protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte junto con la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula fonder Legend el
Primer Ministro británico Richie sunak
anunció el acuerdo marco de Windsor que
modifica el protocolo original y que
según se informó respetará los mercados
y la soberanía de Irlanda del Norte la
aplicación del nuevo marco de Windsor
será gradual recordemos que el protocolo
establece los controles aduaneros entre
el mercado comunitario y el británico en
un contexto post brexit dado que la
salida de Londres del grupo de Bruselas
acabó con la libre circulación entre
territorios escuchemos las palabras de
sunat y de bonder Legend respecto al
nuevo acuerdo
el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea
pudimos haber tenido nuestras
diferencias en el pasado Pero somos
aliados socios comerciales y amigos algo
que vimos claramente el año pasado
cuando nos unimos a otros Para apoyar a
Ucrania
este pequeño
Este es el comienzo de un nuevo capítulo
en nuestra relación durante un cuarto de
siglo el acuerdo del viernes santo de
belfast ha perdurado porque en su
esencia se basa en el respeto por las
aspiraciones y la identidad de todas las
comunidades el acuerdo de hoy trata de
preservar ese delicado equilibrio y
trazar un nuevo camino a seguir para el
pueblo de Irlanda del Norte
podemos enorgullecernos del hecho de que
Hemos cumplido con ese compromiso porque
hoy nos hemos puesto de acuerdo Hemos
llegado a un acuerdo de principio sobre
el marco de Windsor
el marco de Windsor establece nuevos
acuerdos sobre Irlanda Irlanda del Norte
este nuevo marco nos permitirá comenzar
un nuevo capítulo proporciona soluciones
duraderas que Ambos estamos seguros de
que funcionarán para todas las personas
y empresas en Irlanda del Norte
recordemos que desde que empezaron los
diálogos del brexit Londres y Bruselas
han intentado evitar una frontera entre
la República de Irlanda país miembro de
la Unión Europea e Irlanda del Norte
parte del Reino Unido para no revivir el
conflicto no Irlandés se establecieron
Entonces los controles en el mar de
Irlanda pero los unionistas de belfast
consideraban que eso los alejaba del
resto del Reino Unido
previamente hablamos con Oscar Guardiola
profesor del big College University of
London sobre Cuáles han sido las
principales concesiones de ambas partes
para lograr el nuevo acuerdo
quizás la mayor concesión que ha hecho
la Unión Europea tenga que ver con la
capacidad de una suerte de Beto que se
la le ha otorgado al parlamento de
stormand y que le permitiría
inaplicar las normas nuevas que en
materia comercial dicte la Unión Europea
sí se dan una serie de condiciones muy
excepcionales es poco probable que esas
condiciones se den sin embargo ese tipo
de
digamos soberanía compartida en lo
judicial es algo novedoso y una
concesión por parte de la Unión Europea
cambiamos de información en Ucrania las
autoridades de kiev informaron de un
ataque ruso con 14 drones bomba el
ejército ucraniano asegura que pudieron
derribar 11 de los 14 drones que se
dirigían a la capital kiev y al oeste
del país allí el alcalde de
reportó que el ataque causó al menos dos
muertos y tres heridos por otro lado el
kremlin se pronunció este lunes sobre el
plan de paz propuesto por china
Moscú agradeció el apoyo de Beijing pero
concluyó Que de momento no ve
condiciones para una salida de paz
negociada desde cromators nuestra
enviada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel no
reporta lo ocurrido este lunes sobre el
terreno
hoy al clima no ha sido tan malo como
ayer pero como ven llueve a esta hora en
crema y este condiciones climáticas
ayudan a que los enfrentamientos no sean
tan intensos como cuando el cielo está
cubierto especialmente porque los drones
no pueden operar de la misma manera y
terminan siendo los ojos no solamente de
la artillería sino también de la
Infantería esto En un momento en que la
situación en muchos frentes en el donbas
especialmente en bakmuth siguen siendo
inciertos y también a nivel militar el
gobierno del presidente y la presidencia
ha publicado un decreto en el que cesan
a quien fuera el jefe militar de esta
zona del donbas Sin dar mayores motivos
aquí tampoco hay muchas especulaciones
pero la realidad es que la situación no
es fácil tanto para los rusos pero
tampoco para los ucranianos hoy no hemos
tenido mayores noticias de bakmut pero
sí sabemos que aunque siguen teniendo el
control de algunas partes del centro
algunas unidades o batallones estarían
retirando solamente hay una vía de
acceso
como hablábamos ayer y la gran pregunta
es si llegaran a retirarse para
reagruparse y luego volver a atacar Como
lo hicieron por ejemplo en la zona de
Hacia dónde lo harían hemos visto por
ejemplo en la zona de Constantinopla que
está bastante cerca a vacunada y estaba
toda la presencia militar de la zona lo
hemos visto mucho más vacía que lo
veíamos hace un mes por ejemplo sin
saber muy bien hemos visto también
algunas líneas de coches militares salir
pero también otras entrar y esta
situación se repite también en otros
frentes como el de cremita es batove
donde los enfrentamientos continúan
abdica Así que la situación en el don
vas en este momento es bastante crítica
esto es un momento también de cambio de
clima como decíamos están quietos en el
día de hoy a la espera de saber qué va a
pasar en las próximas semanas y meses
donde también se habla de una próxima
ofensiva ucraniana pero esta para
detener las líneas que cortan ese
corredor entre el donbas y la isla de
crimea Pero esto todos son
especulaciones y posibilidades
este lunes el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron presentó su plan de
relaciones con el continente africano
para este mandato esto en un contexto
decreciente recelo por la herencia
colonial francesa y por la continuada
influencia de la ex metrópolis en África
macron habló desde el Eliseo A solo días
de un viaje que lo llevará por cuatro
países centroafricanos el mandatario
francés dijo que planea una notable
reducción de las tropas francesas en
África y habló de nuevas relaciones más
igualitarias escuchemos
ya no hablamos de las bases militares
como existen hoy mañana nuestra
presencia se inscribirá
en las escuelas en las academias
congestionadas habrá personal Francés
pero
en menor cantidad y personal áfricano y
sin nuestros amigos africanos lo desean
podrán recibir otros socios de acuerdo
con los intercambios que he tenido esta
semana con mis homólogos esta
transformación comenzará en los próximos
meses con base en el principio mismo de
la construcción de una disminución
visible de nuestros efectivos
Emanuel macron dijo en su discurso que
quería dejar atrás la competición entre
potencias por el control de África sin
embargo también defendió el papel de
Francia en favorecer la influencia
europea en el continente africano un
continente recordemos donde China y
Rusia ganan terreno previamente hablamos
precisamente con el doctor en ciencia
política Luis Jean Pierre loiston sobre
esta ambivalencia en las palabras del
presidente francés los africanos mismos
son escépticos de Estas ideas por qué
Por ejemplo si uno mira bien van a a
reestructurar lo que es la relación de
paternalismo de Francia con África por
ejemplo si uno mira dicen que van a
reducir las visibilidad de los militares
entonces quién va a tomar El reemplazo
de esos militares franceses Son
son blancos son los mismos franceses o
diríamos los colonizaron
colonizadores pero reemplazado por otros
africanos por ejemplo los dictadores
Francia va a adoptar más o menos la
misma política copiar lo que está
haciendo china en África no se mete
prácticamente en la política interna de
África no van a promover lo que es la
democracia como tal sino tratar de como
meterse como para evitar que nos dicen
que Francia es como oto colonizador es
otro que viene a dar órdenes yo creo que
ese discurso los africanos mismo lo
toman con mucho
con mucho como
precaución con mucho duda sobre la
verdadera intención de Francia en este
Nueva Era que él está descubriendo allí
vamos ahora con noticias de América
Latina porque en Ecuador la policía
Investiga el asesinato del líder
indígena Eduardo mendúa quien fue
tiroteado la madrugada de este domingo
en sucumbíos en el noreste del país
cerca de la frontera con Colombia
nuestro corresponsal en Ecuador Gustavo
Ortega con los detalles y las
potenciales consecuencias del incidente
el asesinato del dirigente de relaciones
internacionales de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de Ecuador
Eduardo mendúa ha generado reacciones no
solo en el país sino del propio
representante de los pueblos indígenas
de la ONU el presidente del foro
permanente de asuntos indígenas de la
ONU Darío Mejía Montalvo calificó el
asesinato como repudiable y altamente
preocupante exigió las autoridades
actuar con rapidez y castigar a los
responsables Eduardo mendúa fue
asesinado el 26 de febrero al estilo
sicariato según informó el ministro de
interior Juan Zapata cuando retornaba a
su vivienda la provincia de sucumbíos
por un grupo armado formaba parte de la
nacionalidad indígena cofán que hace
vida en la he amazonía ecuatoriana su
más reciente participación se produjo en
la asamblea nacional de la conae en la
ciudad de Quito donde los movimientos
indígenas le han exigido la renuncia al
cargo al presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso por una supuesta trama
de corrupción y narcotráfico que señalan
a su entorno más cercano sucede cuando
hace siete meses también su hermano
fuera asesinado las organizaciones
indígenas desconfían de los pedidos de
del ejecutivo nacional y han rechazado
la presencia de la actividad minera y
petrolera en sus territorios sin
consulta previa los movimientos
indígenas de rechazan la militarización
en treinta nuevos pozos petroleros y 11
explotaciones mineras y aseguran que
tanto el presidente de la república como
la empresa petrolera Estatal tienen
cuotas de responsabilidad por la
militarización de sus territorios y
cuotas responsabilidad por la omisión de
la seguridad en sus zonas sucede en
medio de un clima de atención política
en medio de investigaciones el
presidente de la república los
movimientos indígenas anunciaron
previamente que radicalizarán la
vigilancia a sus territorios y harán una
nueva asamblea para evaluar lo sucedido
mientras la fiscalía anunció la
detención de un primer involucrado en el
asesinato y cerramos con noticias
climáticas porque el invierno en el
hemisferio norte deja inusuales nevadas
en California Estados Unidos además
varios tornados han pasado por el medio
oeste en Oklahoma Kansas y Texas por
otro lado gran parte del territorio de
España se ha visto por la tormenta
juliet Andrés granadillo tiene los
detalles
vientos helados Nevadas regiones
azotadas por Los Fuertes vientos a estos
se enfrentan los habitantes del
hemisferio norte en medio del Invierno
Juliette azota España la tormenta
causada por un frente frío procedente
del Ártico que atacará hasta el jueves
ha dejado 30 provincias bajo la nieve
mientras en Estados Unidos una inusual
helada que cubrió el estado de
California dejó a cientos sin
electricidad en Big Bear cayeron hasta
114 centímetros de nieve Se pinchó un
neumático y tuvimos que cambiarlo pero
Ayer tuvimos que dejar nuestro vehículo
en otro sitio esta mañana cuando nos
dimos cuenta que la rueda estaba
pinchada hubo drama drama drama y ahora
estamos corriendo con la de repuesto y
tenemos que esperar porque el taller al
que íbamos y donde nos iban a ayudar no
está trabajando una advertencia de
ventisca permanecía en efecto para las
montañas de San Bernardino
en Kansas y Oklahoma tornados dejaron
destrucción a su paso vehículos volcados
y una docena de personas quedaron
heridas el servicio meteorológico
nacional con sede Norman Oklahoma Busca
evaluar todo el desastre causado sabemos
de otras áreas donde ocurrieron daños Y
continuaremos inspeccionándolas a medida
que tengamos la oportunidad Si no
podemos llegar a un área inspeccionar
trabajaremos con los administradores de
emergencias locales para evaluar los
daños las tormentas provocaron Vientos
de hasta 112 kilómetros por hora y
cortes de Electricidad debido a la caída
de las redes eléctricas
llegamos así al final de esta emisión a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención saben que pueden ampliar toda
la información en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]